bien du retour à l'école obligatoire
pour tous les élèves dans les écoles et
les collèges à partir du 22 juin
où en es et bien la modification du
protocole sanitaire dans les
établissements scolaires voilà on n'a
pas encore ce protocole alors le
protocole va diffuser dans les
prochaines heures donc aujourd'hui
mercredi il va dans le sens d'un
allègement et donc ça va faciliter aussi
la la préparation des choses pour les
acteurs je dois d'ailleurs les remercier
vous savez les directeurs d'école les
professeurs les inspecteurs principaux
de collèges dont les professeurs aussi
ont eu beaucoup de travail les
collectivités locales
mais c'était pour la bonne cause comme
on dit c'était pour se dé confinement
progressif qui mêlait à la fois le
volontarisme c'est à dire faire revenir
les élèves et en même temps la prudence
parce qu'on doit évidemment faire encore
attention aux enjeux sanitaires
donc il ya plusieurs sujets dans
l'allègement du protocole sanitaire mais
le principal chacun c'est celui la
distanciation physique donc les grandes
règles qui seront par écrit dans le
protocole sanitaire qui sera reçu par
tous les acteurs tout à l'heure c'est
d'une part le fait que à l'école
maternelle et à l'école élémentaire donc
à l'école maternelle
vous n'avez plus de distanciation
physique c'est la même règle que pour
les crèches par réalisme parce qu'on
sait que c'est pas que ça n'est pas
facile de faire respecter cette
distanciation physique et puis parce que
le conseil scientifique nous disait que
pour cet âge là on peut faire cela
d'après les données que nous avons à
l'école élémentaire c'est à ses voisins
puisque l'idée c'est qu'on essaye de
faire respecter un maître mais il ya
certaines classes ou quand on recevra
tous les élèves
parfois on sera obligé d'avoir un peu
moins d'un mètre donc c'est possible à
l'école à l'école élémentaire et puis au
collège la distance d'un mètre doit être
respectée et quand ça n'est pas possible
parfois pour des raisons physiques
locales
alors il doit le port du masque est
obligatoire pour les collégiens lorsque
cette distance d'un mètre mais n'est pas
possible sur le plan latéral voilà
l'essentiel de l'allègement sur plan de
la distance physique après il ya
d'autres sujets beaucoup de choses sont
maintenus à le fait de se laver les
mains
les gestes barrière toutes ces choses
qui au fond sont naturels aujourd'hui
dans notre vie quotidienne
et qui font partie aussi finalement de
l'éducation à l'hygiène et à la santé
que nous développons chez les enfants ce
moment alors concernant ce nouveau
protocole sanitaire
et bien tout à l'heure sur le plateau de
public sénat on avait un débat avec
notamment des représentants des
enseignants qui disait d'ici le 22 juin
nous ne serons pas prêts pour appliquer
ce nouveau protocole qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez si nous serons prêts
l'ensemble de l'institution sera prête
bien sûr c'est une étape supplémentaire
avec du travail supplémentaire mais là
en l'occurrence
les règles de distanciation physique
font que ce sera ce sera faisable
ceux qui vous ont dit cela l'on dit
aussi sans se connaître la nouvelle
nature du protocole sanitaire très bien
merci beaucoup